good morning 47
the board has sanctioned eric soders for
termination
after colorado we did some digging into
soda's private affairs
and discovered that he has been
fast-tracked for critical heart surgery
at the hyper-exclusive gama private
hospital in hokkaido japan
such a display of power has providence
written
all over it sodas who suffers from a
rare condition known as situs inversus
where his internal organs are reversed
desperately needs a right-sided heart
transplant
and has clearly betrayed the ica to get
it
he was admitted last night and is
currently being prepped for a three-day
surgery
we have booked you into gama under the
usual guise of tobias reaper
corporate shark here for a standard
medical checkup
as such you will need to play it by ear
and procure whatever tools you need to
complete the mission
you also need to eliminate yuki yamazaki
a tokyo lawyer who works for providence
sodas has already given yamazaki access
to our client records
and has agreed to provide a full list of
active ica operatives
host operation this transaction
cannot be allowed to happen saudis must
pay for his treachery
and his insidious employers must be
taught a lesson
ica sovereignty is at stake powerful as
providence may be
we need to draw a line in the sand i
will leave you to prepare
welcome to hokkaido 47 the gamma private
hospital
provides cutting-edge medical treatment
for the global elite
outside the law if required the facility
is partially run by an artificial
intelligence system known as
kai the ai oversees patient admission to
various areas in the hospital
and even participates in some medical
procedures
you will find eric sodas in the
operating theatre
undergoing a pre-surgery regenerative
stem cell treatment
a highly controversial procedure yet to
be approved by japanese authorities
yuki yamazaki has already arrived you'll
find her in her suite
or roaming the restaurant in spa areas
of the hospital
so does this schedule to be put under
soon let us make sure he stays that way
good luck 47
hello mr reaper as part of the service
here at gaba
your personal rope has been outfitted
with a radio frequency identification
chip
the device will unlock and allow access
to your personal speed
[Music]
evening sir
oh
yeah it's a good situation miss yamazaki
is very smart
very capable tough as the house too
you should see her in the corner she
seems a bit
i don't know like she's not comfortable
yeah you saw how she dropped her [ __ ]
off the lift crossing the gorge
it's just nicotine cravings oh yeah yeah
that was me five years ago
glad i got that one back hey
we should get her a pack make a good
impression at a place like this
good luck yuki yamazaki
dropped her cigarettes off the lift when
arriving at the hospital
according to her bodyguards this has put
her on edge
maybe you can help quench those cravings
i hope you're enjoying your stay
maybe you can tell me is it true the
boss was
connected no patience this way
sorry for the inconvenience
maybe you can tell me
that's right move on people
spend a lot of time in solitary okay
short version
miss yamazaki is known as the lawyer
that is yuki yamazaki former lawyer to
the yakuza
and current operative for providence
good evening
i feel so good
okay
well it certainly appears that yuki
yamazaki is a fan of yoga
a schedule near the hot springs reveals
that she has booked the trainer all day
feeling flexible 47.
we're okay here
excuse me
but you know what they say right
what's going on
mr jason portman
please come to the hospital entrance
a doctor will escort you to your checkup
hey we don't want no sick people here
okay please just please leave
a doctor will escort you to your
appointment
please proceed to the hospital entrance
uh
useless
so
yeah the cake's alright food's decent
most of the people here
[Applause]
please
ah yeah
that's a little harsh isn't it a total
fan
it's not the chef's fault what was the
kitchen of brent's thinking cutting out
a foogle fish by himself unsupervised
it takes years of practice didn't the
kid realize how poisonous those things
are
yeah he's a kid i probably wanted to
show off i don't know
but anyway the hospital administration
probably thought it would be better to
just ban serving fugu altogether
poor chef that was his best party trick
now what do we do with the last food
cook soup
throw it out i guess it's a damn shame
too
chef refused serving yuki yamazaki
i mean despite constant request
she asked about it just an hour ago it's
really too bad
gama has banned the serving of fugu
following an incident where a guest was
poisoned by a poorly carved piece of the
poisonous fish
it appears however that yuki yamazaki is
trying to sway the chef to slice up his
final specimen
and serve it to her who are we to deny
her such pleasure 47.
[Music]
do you have the right authorization to
be here mister
you're in trouble young man
apparently he'll turn again
[Music]
yes
that's a little harsh isn't it a total
fan
i don't know patient did die
it takes years of practice didn't the
kid realize how poisonous those things
are
yeah he's a kid i mean i probably wanted
to show off i don't know
but anyway the hospital administration
probably thought it would be better to
just ban serving fugu all together poor
chef
that was his best party trick now what
do we do with the last fugue
throw it out i guess it's a damn shame
too
the chef had to refuse serving yuki
yamazaki his signature dish
i mean despite her constant request
she asked about it just an hour ago it's
really too bad no
it's not has banned the serving of food
involving an incident where a guest was
poisoned by a poorly carved piece of the
poisonous fish
it appears however that yuki yamazaki is
trying to sway the chef to slice up his
final special
and serve it to her who are we to deny
her such pleasure 47.
you won't die today
that's for sure
watch this
i mean just the scenery here good
evening
oh god you must think i'm just one giant
contradiction but you know
if you want to be an artist you need to
follow your heart
don't you think well i don't know it's
all
very good evening and i guess you have
to look at it from
everything i hope everything is
hey watch where you're going
but uh i mean most of the time it's just
rubbish
i guess really really expensive
i had several yeah that makes sense
you mind
you know i'm trying to keep calm i i
don't like this
anxiety um excuse me
trespasser trespasser halt
no someone help me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
hey chef you can't come through here use
the kitchen excuse me
a thousand apologies miss but hospital
administration has put a ban
on pufferfish there was an incident
only last week a kitchen apprentice took
it upon him
well i'm sure you can excuse me delicate
sushi
can be saved right here i just prepared
the fresh batch
i knew you would come around eventually
good for you
i hope you like it my colleague is a
straight arrow
me i say it's good to live dangerously
you took the words right out of my mouth
yes hey
[Music]
oh
come on
target down now it's time for soldiers
to retire
[Music]
apparently
um
serene in their simple existence
you're pushing it
sir this area is restricted
only security is allowed i'm american
i don't have restrictions look
let me tell you we are the security of
the free world
you are a part of sin free world right
so you your have your commies gotten
have they gotten to you oh have they
gotten to you too no sir we are a
democracy just like america
but you can't pass through here for
security reasons
ah never mind you i'm wasting my time
here
making the wheel spin i appreciate it
[Music]
always bow remember that
sir stop that
[Applause]
so
yeah i know it's silly but
yes
uh
sir you're not authorized to be here
sorry but you have to leave right away
move along
hate stuff
you
just keep going like that
and we're all clear sir you enjoy the
rest of your day
i'm gonna have to ask you to make a
decision here amigo you can't stay here
hate to be impolite but could you maybe
not be here right now
ugh
that security seems tight today
[Laughter]
huh
[Laughter]
so
[Laughter]
hey
hey what the hell are you doing
just
foreign
so
so
so
that is the right sided donor heart
destined for sodas
this is what he sold out the ica foreign
is good in our line of work
nice and quiet
sometimes i just need a little bit of
action
[Music]
oh
don't
so
[Music]
elegant solution 47 with sodas on the
operating table
and no hope of getting a second
right-sided heart in time
you have effectively killed him without
laying a hand on him
this should be a clear message to anyone
considering following in his footsteps
that's both targets down time to find an
exit
we're done here
so
[Music]
miss burnwood
that's not what my ticket says
we received your message loud and clear
i might add
honestly you could have just sacked the
poor guy
i didn't catch your name no you didn't
there'll be no retaliation not for
sodors nor any other recent fiascos
someone's been meddling in our affairs
killing our operatives and making the
ice look like fools
i think you got close to that someone
closer than we've ever been that's why
we're hiring you
to take him down i don't think so
don't rattle our cages miss burnwood you
really have no idea
you spy on us bribe our people
and you have the call to demand our help
no i can't trust it
even so we've been around for a long
long time i think we could help each
other
some 20 years ago
your agency took in a young man with no
past
and extraordinary skills
in his own special way he cares about
you
and vice versa
and ever since that time you've never
stopped wondering
where he came from and who made him what
he is
there was a doctor some depraved
experiment
but he's gone now ah
well if you believe the questions died
with him
we have nothing further to discuss
if not as i said
i think we could help each other
partners then
cheer up miss burnwood we
we are the lesser evil this terrorist
he wants nothing but chaos
he's only a terrorist if you win
miss brynwood we won a long
time ago this
this is maintenance
[Music]
you